fear sexual harassment was followed by a
brutal murder catalyzing national
attention to the scourge of sexual
violence in our military and helping
advance bipartisan military justice
reform in the 2022
ndaa
this executive order also delivers on a
key recommendation from the independent
review commission to strengthen the
military justice response in prosecuting
cases of domestic violence and fully
implements changes to the ucmj to
criminalize the wrongful broadcast or
distribution of intimate visual images
the biden harris administration thanks
congress for its bipartisan commitment
to pass monumental reforms to our
military justice system and codify key
recommendations from the irc the
independent review commission we also
look forward to continuing to work with
congress to support the safety and
dignity of our service members also
wanted to note that today we hit a major
milestone in our global effort to be the
arsenal of vaccines 400 million doses
shipped to 112 countries
for free with no strings attached to put
america's leadership into perspective we
have shipped four times more free doses
to the world than any other country and
this is on top of our efforts to expand
manufacturing at home and abroad our
close partnerships with manufacturers to
provide their vaccines to hard-hit areas
and our work to turn vaccines into
vaccinations around the globe
last item for you
today the consumer financial protection
bureau launched a new initiative to save
american families billions of dollars a
year in unexpected and hidden fees
charged by banks and financial companies
right now as i'm sure many of you know
banks and credit card companies lock you
in with low rates only to charge you
high fees after the fact if you've ever
used a credit card which i'm sure
everybody in this room has
you are familiar with this um you're
familiar with all those extra fees
balance transfer fees late fees and more
they add up collectively the cfpb
estimates that these junk fees drain
tens of billions of dollars per year
from american families consumers are
already starting to feel the benefits of
the cfpb's work in this space after the
cfpb published a report on bank
overdraft fees in december many large
banks bank of america capital one and
wells fargo announced they would reduce
or eliminate some of these fees that's
an important start but not enough which
is why the cfpb is interested in hearing
about everyday americans experiences
with unexpected fees this latest
initiative by the cfpb was previewed at
this week's
competition council meeting and it's
just one of the ways we are one of the
steps we are taking
to go after excessive fees that
companies use to hide the true cost of
products from airline tickets to
high-speed internet services
agencies are planning
internet service fees i should say
agencies are planning actions over the
coming months that will make prices
clear up front so that consumers can
save money by choosing the best deals
for them let me say one other thing i
know there is a lot of news out there
today so let me reiterate something that
you heard the president say and i also
said over twitter um it's always been
the decision of any supreme court
justice if and when they decide to
retire how they want to announce it and
that remains the case today so we're not
going to have additional details you are
always welcome to ask any questions you
like
at any time and there's a lot of news
out there but i just wanted to say that
at the top josh go ahead
two subjects
so let's say hypothetically
a supreme court justice was to retire
and announce it on his or her own terms
does president biden plan to honor his
pledge to nominate a black woman to the
court well i've commented on this
previously the president has
stated and reiterated
his commitment to nominating a black
woman to the supreme court and certainly
stands by that
for today again i'm just not going to
be able to say anything about
any specifics until
of course uh justice breyer makes any uh
announcement should he decide to make an
announcement okay secondly on ukraine
is the white house publicizing the troop
buildups and the russian dis info
efforts in hopes of deterring moscow and
does the white house think that strategy
is working and are you prepared to
release more details about what you say
russia's been doing
um
yes on the last one as we as we have it
and i think you have all experienced
that in here also at the state
department uh and defense department
briefings and certainly from uh
briefings uh delivered by national
security officials uh senior national
security officials as well i will say
josh that we are much uh more cognizant
of uh the russian disinformation machine
than we were in 2014 and many of you
covered of course the invasion of
ukraine in 2014
and we have made a decision a strategic
decision to call it disinformation when
we see it and all across the federal
government various agencies are working
together to fight disinformation and
correct it in part we know uh the part
that's because we know that russia's
disinformation operation is highly
developed
we are more wiser we are wiser the world
is wiser than they were in 2021 and
russia has a boundless capacity to
misrepresent truth and what it's doing
and some of that tactic from their end
is intended to set the predicate for
them invading and i need to be very
clear with the global community uh and
the u.s public what they're trying to do
and why so there's a lot of efforts
underway to do exactly that in terms of
whether it will have a deterrent effect
i think our biggest uh effort on that in
that regard is laying out the clear
potential consequences but it is also
important and we think strategically
important to be very clear that what
they're trying to convey publicly out
there a lot of that is misinformation
and people need to understand and digest
that
jen what preparations is the white house
engaged in broadly in the case of a
supreme court vacancy i'm just not going
to detail any of that from here
unrelated to this you can't detail what
like doesn't every white house like to
get ahead of this in case of a passing
in the case of ruth bader ginsburg none
of that you can share i'm not going to
detail internal planning from here no
okay and let me ask you a couple other
questions is there any scenario in which
the president would select his vice
president kamala harris for the supreme
court
again i'm not going to speak to any
considerations preparations lists
and as we've stated earlier and you
heard the president say it is there's a
long history of supreme court justices
determining when uh they may retire if
they retire and announcing that uh and
we're going to uh that remains the case
today or more wiser than to take those
questions then so i will ask you about a
different topic that's vladimir putin
the president saying yes that he would
very much consider
um personally sanctioning him in the
case of a russian invasion can you give
us a sense because russia has dismissed
or sort of that idea what would
sanctioning does russia have a role in
determining our sanctions no but they've
said that it would have no impact so
what impact would sanctioning vladimir
putin have on him and what would that
look like
well i think what's important to know
broadly is that what we've also said is
that
it will be far beyond
any sanctions
package would be far beyond what was
done in 2014 and that includes impacting
uh business and economic interests of
president putin and the leadership of
the russian government i would also note
that while it has been our policy
that we are not going to take options
off the table from here and we haven't
we also have been detailed what isn't
isn't in an initial package and that
doesn't mean that everything out there
that's being
talked about isn't an initial package
okay thank you go ahead thank you when
you were asked about the vice president
possibly being selected as a supreme
court nominee you said you're not going
to speak to any considerations does that
mean she is being considered
again peter i'm not going to speak to uh
the reports of a supreme court justice
retirement that hasn't been announced so
theoretically would someone who
theoretically i do like that you preface
it i appreciate that just wondering
hypothetically theoretically would
someone who was an attorney general of a
large state and who served with many key
senate votes be an attractive candidate
to the president for an open supreme
court i see what you did there peter but
the president has every intention uh as
he said before of running for
re-election and for running for
reelection with uh vice president harris
on the ticket as his partner uh but
again i will just reiterate uh that i
have nothing more to offer in terms of
specifics or information on the reports
this morning i don't know
would you have another question yes go
ahead i know there's other things on
your mind on your list over there uh
now that you guys have submitted the
written responses to russia's demands
they are saying
if we do not receive a constructive
answer from the west on our security
demands moscow will take appropriate
measures
is that a threat to appropriate measures
well let me first say that
the aggressor here as maybe you're
echoing in some ways or raising uh is
russia
russia has tens of thousands of troops
at the border
they have the ability also to make the
decision
to
de-escalate uh to bring troops back from
the border to participate in good faith
in a diplomatic conversation and that
would certainly be our preference so
them making threats i think secretary
blinken had a very uh good quote or it
made me laugh uh that he gave a couple
of days ago where he said it was like
the fox threatening to attack the hens
and the hen house because they were
feeling threatened by the hens uh but uh
our objective is to give them paths and
to uh take part in a diplomatic
conversation in good faith and as the
russians talk about appropriate measures
if one of those winds up being a russian
cyber attack like dhs is warning about
you guys consider that an act of war
well peter we have talked many times
before first of all there's no
no information we have at this point
about any imminent threat against the
u.s homeland we are always prepared for
cyber threats from a range of sources um
and we have a range of uh tools at our
disposal to use in ra and reaction and
the president reserves the right to do
that but i'm not going to get into a
hypothetical and then on covet origins
you guys are talking a lot about
sanctions for russia if they dare to
invade ukraine
what about sanctions for china at any
point
for misleading the world about
the early days of the global pandemic
we've used sanctions as a tool as it
relates to our concerns about the
behavior of a range of countries
including officials in china but i have
nothing to preview for you at this point
is it possible down the line though that
they
that sanctions would be considered some
other form of punishment
for
their actions in the earliest days of
the pandemic well you know we strongly
believe and the president has been clear
and directly clear about the importance
of them being transparent and providing
data and information
related to the origins of the pandemic
but i don't have anything to predict for
you in terms of additional actions so
then my last one would be the president
said for months that he had not spoken
directly to xi about the covet origins
investigation
now he says that he did talk to she
about it but nobody else was there
if the president had that conversation
did it work and is she now playing ball
what are you getting out there are you
suggesting the president wasn't being
honest about his own conversation with
she no but the story did change uh for
months he was asked about it and he said
that he had not directly asked him about
the
origins we don't share every detail of
every diplomatic conversation you know
that uh the president answered a direct
question just a week ago or i think it
was a week ago yes um and
provided that information
okay
go ahead thank you um when was the last
time the president talked to justice
prior have they have any communication
today
i don't have any more details of their
communications
um
i wonder if you can clear this up
because there seems to be some
disagreement among some legal scholars
is it your understanding and the
understanding of this administration
that the vice president can
be the tie-breaking vote to confirm a
nominee to the court
i would have to check on the specifics
of that
one more on the president's uh supreme
court commission i believe they they
finished their report they turned in
last month as the president had a chance
to review this might we hear from him on
any decision or input that he said uh he
has received the report i don't have any
update on his analysis of it at this
point in time
go ahead
i'm taking you somewhere completely
different okay let's go there the china
bill yes which the president last night
in the statement said
he's hired by the bipartisan work on the
package which it was in the senate not
so much in the house
uh foreign affairs committee chairman
mccall said it was absolutely not
bipartisan will likely garner no
republican support
are you guys involved in and if so
in getting this to a bipartisan package
eventually
um and what are your priorities in that
3 000 page fill since it is
pretty long
um and is your timeline the state of the
union what are you looking at here well
um i would say first that it did receive
extensive bipartisan support in the
senate vote right in the senate version
uh that our objective is uh certainly
remains um
ensuring that this passes as soon as
possible and the president can sign it
as soon as possible i don't have a new
deadline or timeline for you we believe
that bipartisan comp competitiveness
legislation will help us tackle supply
chain issues and inflation head on and
will make investments in american
manufacturing and our economic strength
so we can out-compete china uh and we're
certainly advocating that and have been
advocating that and deeply involved in
conversations with uh the house and
senate uh and our objective is certainly
uh that to have legislation passed that
can take a range of uh steps uh
strengthening r d boosting manufacturing
with us in important and imperative
funding uh for chips manufacturing chips
so we can
make sure we bring down the cost of cars
as we know which is leading to one third
of the inflationary pressure out there
in the country
we want this legislation to help
businesses and communities in every
corner of the country out compete their
global competitors in terms of specifics
as you noted it's quite a long bill
we're certainly involved in engaging it
uh with officials from throughout the
administration uh but i'm not going to
detail specifics of what we're foreign
against in it either is there any um
possibility that should this play out
you know sort of
similar to the
infrastructure bill take a long time
house republicans will not get on board
that you given the pressure of the chips
shortage on inflation that you just take
out the strip
strip out the chips portion pass that
individually and then negotiate on the
rest do you see that i'm not going to
make a prediction of that at this point
i mean as i understand it the status of
the legislative process is that uh both
the house and senate have indicated that
it will go to conference and they'll
work out uh disagreements that they have
over components of the legislation uh
also the senate version had 68 votes and
certainly we believe that
increasing and improving america's
competitiveness and investing in r d
research and development
and making sure we're more competitive
in communities across the country is not
a partisan idea so we are hopeful about
uh that process moving forward quickly
and the president would certainly like
to sign it as soon as possible and then
one more on this bill too that is a
difference between the house and the
senate version the house version
published last night had this outbound
investment screening mechanism that
wasn't part of the senate bill
it would potentially block investments
in countries like china
uh does the white house support this
provision and will you fight that that's
gonna make it in the final package
that's reaching the president's desk
i'm not gonna get into specifics of the
bill uh i would tell you that we are in
daily contact uh from the white house um
with house and senate leadership and
committees and we're discussing the path
forward but we're not going to negotiate
the pieces from here is there anything
you can tell us on the work the
executive branch is doing on exactly
that same thing because jake sullivan
has been talking about a potential
mechanism like this being interesting to
you guys and
potentially working on this but we
haven't heard about it in a while i can
see if there's any additional update
from the national security team of
course and certainly i know he's talked
about that in the past and it remains a
priority go ahead uh i have to give a sh
give it a shot myself as well go ahead
uh in this hypothetical alternative
reality where a retirement a vacancy
were to open up could you say who within
the white house would be sort of leading
the charge on the selection vetting
process
as the president said i'm sure that uh
if and when there is an announcement by
justice breyer there will be more to be
said and we'll have more conversation in
here i'm sure he'll have more to say but
i'm not going gonna have anything more
for you at this point um just switching
gears uh on the energy front uh the
administration said on tuesday it's in
talks with major energy producing
countries and companies around the world
over a potential diversion of supplies
to europe if russian-based ukraine have
any of the energy companies or countries
contacted by the administration told you
that they do indeed have an ability to
divert extra supplies to europe
uh well that's been part of the
conversation but i don't have any
announcements to make on their behalf
but certainly that's been our objective
is to ensure that we are prepared uh for
the possibility of the supply the
natural gas supply which as you know is
very much a regional issue and there
would be a big regional impact less so
here in the united states as well as the
global oil supply and ensuring there is
enough supply in the market what do you
see is the risk of the contingency
planning failing to secure europe's
energy supply since our reporting
suggests so far that the industry has
little or no capacity to do this
there are no question there are
logistical challenges of especially
moving uh natural gas we know that uh
that's part of our discussion with a lot
of these companies and countries
but again these conversations are
ongoing and we don't intend to fail on
them thank you god
a number of lawmakers sent a letter to
the white house today including chuck
schumer and elizabeth warren
asking the white house to release the
memo that the education department uh
put together looking at the president's
legal authority to cancel student loan
debt i i wonder do you have a response
to that and you know why hasn't this
memo been released well let me first say
no one uh has paid uh or been required
to pay a single dime of federal student
loans since the president took office
over a year ago uh and i'll also add
that our country is seeing one of the
strongest economic recoveries in history
and the pause announced in december give
some breathing room for several more
months to borrowers who are still coping
with the pandemic the education
department will continue working to
ensure a smooth transition to repayment
i would reiterate also that the
president supports congress on members
of the who sent the letter and others uh
sending him a bill uh that would uh
provide ten thousand dollars in debt
relief uh and he continues to look into
what debt relief actions can be taken
administratively um i'd also note that
uh in terms of loans that have been
forgiven since the president took office
beyond the pause on repayment a total of
15 billion dollars benefiting more than
675 000 student loan borrowers
as part been part of the forgiveness
borrower defense to repayment 1.5
billion total and permanent disability
repayments uh
loans forgiveness i should say 7.8
billion itt tech students 1.3 billion
and public service loan forgiveness 5
billion so we have been doing a broad
range of forgiveness and also have had
this pause in place meaning that no one
who has student loans has been required
to pay since the president took office
the white house plan to release the memo
like does the the white house plan to
tell the public whether it thinks has
the authority to cancel too as i said
again we're still looking at
administrative options but congress can
also send the president a bill
that would provide ten thousand dollars
in debt relief and he'd uh be happy to
sign that bill on the trip uh on friday
to pittsburgh can you talk a little bit
more about why the president is taking
this trip is this about the president
getting out more i know that he talked
about that last week that he wanted to
get out and you know be face to face
with people is that what this is about
that's part of it um i i think if the
president could spend every day out on
the road he might do that there are of
course a lot of responsibilities as
president that don't make that possible
so that is certainly part of that and i
expect you'll see him out on the road uh
more in the coming weeks as well
it's also an opportunity for him to
speak about his economic agenda and what
steps he's taking to make people's lives
better to lower costs for americans to
rebuild their communities to make us
more competitive
but certainly to interact uh with people
in communities those who disagree with
him and those who agree with him as well
just quickly on the executive order
that's being signed later on today
is that is that order coming out because
the ndaa did not do enough to address
the issue of sexual harassment like
why is this order needed
uh it was a key recommendation from the
independent review commission so it's
delivering on the independent review
commission's recommendation
which is something that was supported
these recommendations and delivering on
them by the leadership of the department
of justice so it's an effort to
implement that
go ahead i wanted to start with a
question on behalf of a colleague on the
radio network who wants to know if you
have any update on the launch of
buildback better world which was
supposed to i guess be implemented
earlier this year
and it would delete sings upcoming trip
to africa include scouting projects for
the ultimate better world i'm happy to
check with our national security team we
have talked about buildback better world
and been working a lot behind the scenes
on efforts to launch that around the
world and the president has talked about
it on all virtually all of his foreign
trips to date but i can see it uh get
more specifics about the leaves trip and
um on the meeting the president had
today with the the ceos about buildback
better
here
is the the strategy now with sort of the
president talking about breaking it up
in chunks potentially
is the plan to bring a new proposal to
democrats in congress what what does
that strategy look like as it relates to
kind of the meeting that he had today is
he trying to get a sense of what the
priorities would be from these private
sector ceos the the meeting was not a
negotiation it was not the basis of a
negotiation those discussions will
happen between the 50 members of the
senate who need to support a package a
big chunk
to move it forward
this was an opportunity to hear from
business leaders and i think you heard a
number of them speak during the open
press component of the meeting and i
know a number of them will be doing
interviews maybe with some of you after
awards as well
what i think was interesting and
compelling to the president when we were
talking about this last night was that
they're all experiencing
different challenges as they look ahead
to their many of them very successful
businesses some of that is ensuring they
can
have enough women at a senior level in
the workforce and lowering the cost of
child care and making that affordable is
a big issue that the ceo of etsy has
talked about for example quite a bit the
ceo of cummins has talked a lot about
climate change or the climate agenda and
the importance of investing in that and
moving forward because those are
industries that will grow and have a
huge opportunity for our manufacturing
industries here in the united states
those are all components that are part
of the president's buildback better
agenda but he really wanted to hear from
them on their industries of the best way
to grow their businesses the middle
class and
how components will will certainly
impact them is that a message the
president plans to take to democrats is
he going to present something smaller a
big chunk sort of a more narrow
piece of legislation or proposal that
perhaps can
can get unstuck in the senate well again
i don't have any predictions of the
legislative process this was not a
meeting about the legislative process
the president and members senior members
of our legislative team and senior white
house officials are in constant contact
with the range of senators committee
members staffers
and really the point we're at now is
determining what components there can be
50 votes for and that will hopefully
include a big big chunk of what the
president has proposed but that's what
the status of that is but this was not a
meeting to discuss legislative strategy
uh or uh how to navigate conversations
with different senators
go ahead yeah jen i have a couple more
on bbb um ron klein said last week that
we'd like to see bbp legislation
approved as quickly as possible some
democrats representative jayapal are
saying that march 1st the state of the
union is kind of a deadline for action
does the white house see it that way in
terms of the time frame do you see this
no we have not set a deadline no
and the five democratic senators wrote
the president and the vice president
urging them to keep the channel tax
credit expansion in bbb but the
president's increased here in the press
conference he wasn't sure that that
could happen
is he reviewing that did he change his
mind well the president proposed the
child tax credit extension he very much
wants to see the child tax credit
extended and you've all heard him talk
about how proud he is of the expanded
child tax credit because of the impact
it had on cutting childhood poverty by
40 percent for giving people some extra
breathing room and there are some recent
studies and evidence that the child tax
credit helps working families in the
developments
and opportunities for all children so he
has long been an advocate again this is
the legislative process right and there
needs to be 50 votes we need every
democrat to support a package moving
forward i don't have anything to preview
or predict for you on that front that is
going to be up to them to determine what
that looks like
one more um
should you have a supreme court
nomination that has to make its way
through the senate
is there any concern that that could
crowd out priorities like go back better
make it that much harder to get
something done here
uh not without getting into any
specifics of what may be on the docket
uh we have to walk and chew gum at the
same time here in the white house and
that includes navigating uh you know the
build-up of military troops on the
border of ukraine that includes trying
to
get an omnibus bill passed and get our
competition bill passed that includes
continuing to be the arsenal of vaccines
to the world and we are
entirely capable of doing more than one
thing at once
go ahead in the back thank you jen i
have two questions two different topics
okay just one um on ukraine is about the
supreme court
no actually no i'm not part of this um
the president earlier this week said he
talked to all nato leaders
uh canada has offered a 100 million loan
to ukraine
and is considering could be announced
this afternoon
further support assistance
what type of contribution um does the
president think canada could make to
this crisis
well we will
we would we will the support of canada
and any country that is contributing to
the uh the needs of ukraine uh that is
uh defending the territorial integrity
of ukraine uh and defending what we feel
is a fundamental uh value that we share
with canada and a number of countries
around the world which is the fact that
new countries should be able to invade
and territory of another country uh so
we're not going to assess
what they should do or not do every
country has different capacities
capabilities legal authorities we
recognize that but we certainly welcome
their support for ukraine
as an ask for arm shipments or troops
i'm not going to get into any more
details of conversations we just
recognize that every country has
different capabilities capacities
authorities uh and a range of
contributions uh and doing it in a
coordinated way we think is very
effective i'd like to talk about i have
a question about haiti okay
so canada hosted an international
meeting last week
uh prime minister trudeau has called for
uh immediate action to fix the security
situation in haiti you know that then uh
uh
in the next two weeks it would have been
the end of president jonatha's term uh
if he hadn't been assassinated what's
the u.s plan particularly in terms of
security
knowing that there's no
newly elected president to swore in on
on february 7th
well let me first reference and i think
you're probably aware of this but last
week deputy secretary wendy sherman
participated in a high-level uh
ministerial hosted by canada to discuss
sustainable inclusive solutions to the
challenges faced by haiti and haitians
the ministerial was an opportunity for
global leaders or high level officials
to
reaffirm the continued international
commitment to support haiti as it
confronts growing insecurity works to
restore its democratic institutions and
revives the country's economic
development we're also continue to work
with haitian authorities and
international partners to provide
additional assistance from the united
states to the haitian national police to
strengthen law enforcement build up
anti-gang operations maintain peace and
stability and we have also in response
to heightened humanitarian needs in
haiti usaid has provided more than 92
million dollars in assistance in fiscal
year 2021 so we're working on a range of
channels including in close coordination
with other leaders about how we can help
prop up humanitarian needs address their
security needs and act in a coordinated
way as haiti looks to their future
go ahead just a quick question on
inflation
many people believe that government
spending is a big factor in the current
inflation levels can you speak to
concerns that spending plans that come
out of buildback better aren't paid for
and so could mean higher deficits and
more inflation in the future aren't you
paid for
buildback better is paid for
entirely
okay can you speak to the concerns that
are coming in that it's who are the
concerns from though
but who's saying it's not paid for
because there have been a range of
economists saying it's entirely paid for
um and that has been a priority for the
president it has also been concluded by
a number of nobel laureates and experts
from a range of economic experts on the
outside that it will not contribute to
inflation so those are the global
experts that we would point to but there
may be others suggesting something else
but i don't know who those people are
those bills do pass it will not raise
taxes
well it something being entirely paid
for means that part of that is the
highest income americans highest that
companies would be asked to pay a little
bit more that has been part of the
proposal and part of reforming the tax
system to make it more fair
they're also not expected to contribute
to future inflation then
the buildback better bill
again it's fully paid for we would point
to nobel laureates and a range of global
economists who have conveyed that it
would not contribute to inflationary
pressures go ahead thanks jen i wanted
to ask about the impact that president
biden's experience and foreign policy
has on the his handling of the current
situation
with russia and ukraine obviously he
served on the senate foreign relations
committee he was vice president when
russia invaded crimea he oversaw the end
of the war in afghanistan last year can
you just talk about how those various
experiences have informed his decision
making
and his thinking on the
situation currently with russia and
ukraine absolutely so one of the the
lessons learned we talked about i talked
about a little bit earlier in response
to josh's question which is uh the the
ability and the uh boundless capacity of
russia to
misrepresent the truth uh and spread
misinformation through a range of
channels i mean they have a range of
state-run media channels that are not
just prevalent in russia but around
eastern europe across europe you can
even find them in the united states but
even beyond that this is the capacity
that we've seen them utilize in 2014 and
2016 and many times in between
so one of the lessons that we have
learned is certainly the president has
learned is certainly that uh it's
important to call out this
disinformation um and to make clear uh
to the american public to the global
community what they're trying to do here
and the fact that it is not accurate
they're trying to set the predicate for
war we've done that through a number of
means last week the administration
announced sanctions on four of course
ukrainian individuals we also had a
briefing launched a website released a
fact sheet to educate the public on the
russia disinformation ecosystem the fbi
and dhs are coordinated with the
intelligence community as well as state
and local partners to ensure common
understanding of russia disinformation
and influence activities related to the
situation in ukraine so that's one part
i'd also say that for the president this
has been a priority for him since he
came into office building up our
alliances and partnerships uh with the
global community ensuring that close
coordination is uh front and center and
is a priority is something that he has
learned through his time in uh foreign
policy uh as the former chair of the of
the foreign relations committee of
course as vice president is imperative
uh and we believe that's proving to be
very effective at this point in time
we've had more than 100 probably way
more than that at this point engagements
with nato partners allies around the
world um and we have a coordinated and
strong um uh you know approach to how
we're approaching the build-up of troops
on the border of ukraine so there are
many lessons but i would say those are
two of the biggest ones all right and
can i also ask about the um china
competitiveness bill sure mentioned
earlier um does the white house want to
see congress finish work on that before
build back better is there like a
priority there in terms of getting that
done the president would like to sign it
as soon as possible but beyond that i
i'm not going to get into an order of
events
go ahead thank you jen i have a few
questions the first on the supreme court
um does the president believe that the
current makeup of the court accurately
reflects america's demographics
well i would say the president as you
know asked for uh it put together a
commission that could uh review that is
by a commission made of democrats and
republicans of a range of illegal views
that could take a look at everything
from the makeup of the court to how they
select uh cases to the length of service
to the size of the court that's a report
as mary asked about earlier that he
certainly has i don't have an update on
his review of that at this point in time
i will i will note though for you to go
directly to your question he has
nominated uh a historic number of uh of
judges uh who are people of color a
historic uh i don't know if it's a
stroke number of women but a a majority
of the judges he has nominated are women
that speaks to his desire and his
interest in having courts around the
country that look like america and that
represent the experiences of america
including public defenders and others so
that is the evidence of his commitment
to that i would point to is it the
expectation of the president in the
white house that whomever he would
nominate for any hypothetical vacancy
that that would be an appointment that
democrats could unify behind
well that's always the hope if there
were if if that if that opportunity
presents itself go ahead in the back
thanks john um the pace of americans who
are getting booster shots has dropped by
more than 50 since december and public
health experts are saying that one cause
that might be behind that is confusion
over the cdc's distinction between being
fully vaccinated and being up to date on
vaccinations um folks who might have
spoken say that initially describing the
two dose regimen for mrna vaccines may
have been premature
uh given what we now know about variants
and breakthrough cases was it a mistake
to say that people were fully vaccinated
back last year before we knew
what the virus was going to do next well
that it was not a decision made by the
white house it was a decision made by
our public health experts at the cdc who
make those definitions or determine
those definitions
they've also said that the term
fully vaccinated refers to your primary
series so that means being up to date on
your vaccines which is true if you have
kids i have kids making sure they're up
to date when they go to the doctor you
ask them if they need any shots
that is true of when you need a booster
shot you needed a set number of months
depending on what vaccine you got
past your second dose
that's something we think american
people are more than capable of keeping
up to date on it is also true that we
think more people need to get boosters
that boosters are very effective in
protecting
against serious illness hospitalization
and that uh that is one of the most
effective steps that can be taken 70
percent of eligible seniors have gotten
their boosters but certainly it needs to
be higher in other age groups
do you have one on the news today i'm
sorry
don't need to be sorry okay you're doing
your job um so
if justice fire were to retire one of
the last cases that he'll face as a
member of the supreme court obviously
will be dobbs versus jackson which court
washroom is saying is likely to weaken
or potentially overturn rugby
if his potentially final opinion ends up
being a dissent in the dom's case what
is the administration's plan to protect
abortion access as best it can be on
trying to pass a congressional remedy
which i think
you know unless you guys have ten extra
senators lying around who might not be
able to be the filibuster well without
speaking uh to uh the future of the
supreme court uh what i will reiterate
is that uh the president has been
advocate for codifying roe uh that's
something he certainly thinks and hopes
that congress will act on
we've also taken steps and have
announced steps in recent
days even to for hhs to support to amp
up their support uh for providers across
the country
and that's something we will continue to
look for ways to do but i'm not going to
make a prediction of the outcome thanks
everyone
not yet uh hopefully we'll have it
race in soon
uh i would just say that um the
president obviously the fed is
independent and we stand by that as does
the president uh that the chairman
powell has indicated his plans to
recalibrate in the past and the
president spoke last week to his support
for that
thank you everyone
you